these are the doctors and nurses at the
front line
the second wave is here
spain's capital madrid is europe's new
corona virus hotspot
but medical staff say they're ready
we're getting patients into intensive
care as soon as possible
and if need be we're putting them on
ventilators earlier than usual
there's some good news the speed of new
infections in spain is waning
but that could change
whatever the case madrid is back under
lockdown
a great deal of europe is reintroducing
restrictions as
infections spike berlin is imposing a
curfew from saturday
parts of the city are now hot spots in
germany daily coronavirus cases have hit
a new high since april
rising hospital rates have health
officials worried in the uk the
government's reviewing measures
in iceland pubs clubs and arcade halls
and gyms are closed
there are fears the latest wave of
infections could be much higher than the
first
and paris has shut its bars but there's
resistance
this is pathetic when you look at what's
happening with public transport
people are crammed together in metros
and buses
i think it's stupid it's a political
issue the government is constantly
manipulating people
left right and center with economic
interests
running an economy and keeping a
pandemic at bay is a balancing act
so far the virus hasn't overwhelmed
germany's hospitals
but they're in a better position to
tackle this second wave
bruno tegel had just started working
here at the helios clinic in berlin
when the coronavirus pandemic reached
germany
the young assistant doctor is still
impressed by just how
quickly the hospital reacted in march
for example we reallocated parts of the
central surgery room
to be used as a new intensive care unit
within 24 hours
along with that entire coronavirus
treatment centers were set up in berlin
equipment was scarce and management were
worried there weren't enough ventilators
many hospitals had to improvise the
first wave of infection took the helios
clinic
by surprise
as far as testing capacities are
concerned in terms of masks and
protective clothing
we are prepared we know where and when
to hospitalize patients
we can make quick diagnoses and quick
decisions
everyone who arrives at the hospital is
tested for coronavirus before they're
admitted
and patients are strictly separated
those who test negative
go to the green ward those who test
positive
go to the red ward and suspected cases
go to the yellow ward
bruno tegel feels this system is safe
we haven't seen a single case of
patients infecting staff
since these measures were initiated now
treating coronavirus patients
has become routine
the applause once heard from german
balconies has quietened down
people seem to have forgotten the
significance of health care workers
that so many coronavirus deniers have
taken to the streets in recent weeks
is something nurses and doctors struggle
to understand
some people say i've never seen
coronavirus so i don't believe in it
well i've never seen electricity but i
don't put my finger in the socket
we've seen coronavirus here we've seen
death
bruno tegel has also seen the effects of
the coronavirus
first hand but he knows that his
hospital is well prepared
for what the pandemic might bring well
monica gandhi is an infectious disease
doctor and researcher with the
university of california san francisco
monica great to have you on the show
what do the rising rates new lockdowns
and
latest preparations all tell you
you know we are either in a second wave
or more likely the continuation of our
first wave and unfortunately
we haven't gotten on top of this covid
pandemic
the cases are still rising and they've
been rising in germany and throughout
the united states
and in europe however death rates are
staying lower than they were during the
first wave
what do you call lockdowns though a
blunt instrument in the fight against
the coronavirus
because lockdowns are extremely
disruptive
to the economy to the poor to workers
to so many aspects of other aspects of
public health
and there are other ways that we can
stay safe
from infection and those pillars of
pandemic control
are essentially social distancing
wearing masks
hand hygiene ventilation
doing things outside when we can and
staying away from large crowds
the complete lockdowns are a completely
blunt instrument that have affected
aspects of public health that we're
going to have ramifications
for so long talking about crowds we've
seen huge protests uh
also here in berlin against these
lockdowns
i mean are they justified or or is it uh
quite uh counterproductive considering
these people are all coming together and
mainly not wearing masks
so it's completely counterproductive to
be in large
crowds without masks so there is
absolute full acknowledgement of the
seriousness of this disease
and we have to completely change life as
we know it
wearing masks is unusual um
complete social distancing is unusual
not having large cloud
crowds is different um having
settings where we are keeping to small
cohorts of groups doing things outside
keeping things ventilated
all of this is different life is
different
but it is risky to be in large crowds
without masks
in the setting of a pandemic i was also
just talking to friends in sweden
they're not wearing masks the bars
are full why are they so relaxed
you know sweden is a very interesting
case that will be looked at
for her for years and and decades to
understand what happened
there is social distancing at the
beginning there was
sort of a recommendation to the public
to stay away from each other
there were a lot of deaths at the
beginning very unfortunately
because a lot of their vulnerable older
people people in nursing homes died
and whether there is more immunity in
the population is being speculated i
think that's likely true
um they do stay away from each other in
general but you're right
things are much more normal in sweden
they took a different strategy
uh they are in a different place um but
it was
at high expense at the beginning in an
interview you said
how much virus you breathe in is
probably one of the most important
determinants of
how sick you get do you still stand by
that
yes you know we and others have been
looking at that question
of the viral dose or the viral inoculum
the amount that you get in
is proportional to how sick you get and
we've not only been looking at this with
chronovirus this is actually
been shown in measles dengue salmonella
many other infectious diseases
we're putting together a review paper on
this now but the main thing is that if
this is true with coronavirus
social distancing and wearing that mask
reduces the amount of virus you get in
and the likelihood that you're going to
become ill and this
seems to make sense in animal models
um and what we've been seeing with this
virus including decreasing mortality
in places that are consistent with
facial masking
monica two quick questions for you what
do you think about your
president's message that he's sending to
the rest of the world
i think uh president trump's message is
dangerous
and ridiculous and he has been um
flouted almost all public health
recommendations except for testing he
doesn't mask he doesn't socially
distance
he keeps large crowds he doesn't contact
trace in the case of this disaster he
didn't isolate
he didn't encourage quarantining he just
tested
that is only one strategy of the
pandemic and it's not enough
and and lastly if you can sum it up in
in one word
what's going to end this pandemic
you know it is not being normal for
at least a year plus the vaccine on top
of it so it is
wearing masks staying away from each
other hand washing
um and then waiting for that safe and
effective vaccine
but not completely shutting down society
you heard it from monica gandhi thank
you very much for being on the show
today
thank you and now it's derek williams
chance to answer your questions on the
coronavirus
if you want us to look into something in
particular just write to us on our
youtube channel
if i've recovered from covid19 do i
still have to wear a mask
sometimes it's easy to forget that that
millions and millions of people
worldwide have also
recovered from covet 19 and want to
return as much as possible
to life as usual but what does coming
out the other end
mean um are you safe from the disease
because you're immune
can you still pose a potential danger to
others do you need to continue to social
distance and
and and wear a mask it's all questions
that we still don't have
a firm answers to we just have to guess
and rely on
what we know from other infectious
diseases particularly
those caused by other coronaviruses
based on what we've seen so far with
covet 19 people do acquire
some immunity the problem is we don't
know for how long
on average what we do know is that with
other coronaviruses that infect humans
immunity can wane pretty swiftly
there are a number of studies that
convincingly show
that people can be reinfected with some
of them within a year
and there have been a few isolated
documented cases
of that also happening with covid19 also
at least in some of those cases the
people who were reinfected
showed no symptoms the second time
around so
were they infectious to others we don't
know
and to me it seems like in general that
until we have
better data when it comes to questions
that we have to answer with
we don't know we should be airing on the
side of caution
so in the face of this particular
we don't know i'd go for the fallback
position which is to continue to assume
that masking up is a way to protect
yourself
and others even if you've recovered from
covid19
[Music]